das ist ein erschreckender anblick
zeugnis eines unvorstellbaren
gewaltexzesses eine verstörende tat im
berliner rotlicht milieu eine sexpuppe
die von einem freier in bestialische art
und weise zu gerichtet wird diskutiert
das ganze auch anmuten mag der fall
bietet allen grund zur sorge und wird
auch von den behörden sehr ernst
genommen
grotesk verbogene gliedmaßen ein
vertreter und halb skalpiert kopf ist
kratz und ein stich spuren vor allem an
den lebensechten silikonbrüsten und am
tor so so die spuren am tatort des
berliner puppen models sei brutal wie in
jedem anderen modell kann man auch
hierfür geld sex haben einziger
unterschied in diesem etablissement
stehen dem freier dafür ausschließlich
puppen zur verfügung zum glück muss man
sagen wenn man sich diese brutale tat
anschaut was war geschehen ein bislang
nicht identifizierter täter mietet sich
in der nacht zum vergangenen samstag
eine der lebensechten sexpuppen für eine
vermeintliche liebesnacht was er nach
dem liebesakt von dem täuschend echten
lustobjekt übrig lässt lässt einen
erschaudern besonders makaber im puppen
hof kann der kunde über eine in die
puppe integrierte gegensprechanlage mit
einer schauspielerin samt
verführerischer stimme interagieren laut
bild-informationen nutzte der puppen
folterer diesen service auch er spricht
während seiner gewalt hat mit der
zugeschalteten schauspielerin darüber
wie gern er seine gewaltfantasien doch
in der realität ausleben möchte
offenbart sich hier ein potenzieller sex
killer
überwachungskameras des etablissements
zeichnen dieses foto des täters beim
verlassen der räumlichkeiten auf er
hinterlässt nicht nur ein verwüstetes
puppen puff zimmer in eine vollkommen
zerstörte sexpuppe er lässt auch die
ausliegenden sexspielzeuge verschwinden
entstandene sachschaden rund 4000 euro
umgehend wurde anzeige gegen den noch
unbekannten täter erstattet
tatvorwurf
vandalismus und diebstahl die tat an
sich die lässt die ermittler und den
betreiber mit einem mulmigen gefühl
zurück schlosser vandalismus oder doch
die tat eines potenziell gefährlichen
triebtätern
und zugeschaltet ist jetzt der professor
für kriminalistik hier in berlin
christian im matzdorf schön dass sie bei
uns sind in dieser fall der schockiert
obwohl eigentlich nur einen sachschaden
entstanden ist muss man ja sagen aber
deutet dieses verhalten darauf hin dass
da jemand gefährliches frei rumläuft
schönen guten morgen hört man die bilder
stehen weil sie erinnern an das was wir
aus der kriminalistik kennen das
sogenannte über töten insbesondere so in
beziehungen wo geschlechter indifferente
dinge geklärt werden dann ein täter
möglicherweise mit viel viel emotionaler
ladung auf einen menschen auf eine frau
im regelfall geht und dann mit
entsprechenden werkzeugen mit messern
möglicherweise mehr macht als nötig ist
um den menschen zu tode zu bringen das
ist die erste assoziation ob das ein
gefährlicher täter hier in diesem fall
ist der sich an der puppe vergangen hat
das liegt im bereich der spekulation wir
wissen dass es einschlägige foren gibt
auch in den kammern kannibalismus foren
wo man zwar fantasien äußert fantasien
ausgelebt aber noch lange nicht dann
über geht daran es tatsächlich so etwas
an echten lebenden menschen
auszuprobieren
das kommt ja eben wie sie auch gerade
schon sagten relativ häufig vor was
meinen sie denn wie sich das eventuell
entwickeln kann wenn man jetzt eben
solche von solchen taten hört leben
solche täter diese diese vorstellung
beziehungsweise diese gewalttaten eben
vor allen dingen an puppen aus oder gibt
es dann auch wirklich noch eine höhere
gefahr durch solche menschen für die
realen menschen
selbstverständlich sollte man im vorfeld
dieser art ernst nehmen das machen die
ermittlungsbehörden ja auch das haben
sie selber den bericht dargestellt ich
bin nicht sicher ob man in jedem fall
wirklich davon ausgehen kann dass jemand
diese schwelle von der ausgelebten
fantasie hier an einer puppe an einem
lieblosen objekt dann tatsächlich
umsetzt und sich an entsprechenden
frauen hier postierten vergehen das ist
tatsächlich eine spekulative sache die
sehr stark mit der einzelnen
individuellen persönlichkeit des täters
hierzu vermengt und vor dem hintergrund
können wir momentan nur mutmaßen aber
aufmerksamkeit und vorsicht ist auf
jeden fall angezeigt wir gehen die
beamten da jetzt vor denn selbst wenn
sie den mann finden dann kann man ja
sagen dass es trotzdem nur eine
sachbeschädigung wie kann man überhaupt
ermitteln wie kann man überhaupt
rausfinden ob eine potenzielle gefahr
dass man ausgeht
ja sie haben richtig gesagt die
strafermittlungen dem fall sind
wahrscheinlich eher sogar nachfrage
nicht zu führen wichtig ist dass wir
gefährdungen gefahren für andere
menschen abwenden und ihr star
vermittlungs behörden werden versuchen
diesen mann namhaft zu machen eine
mögliche gefährderansprache ist denkbar
vielleicht gibt es auch angebote
therapeutische andere art die hier
forciert werden können das hängt aber
tatsächlich ganz stark davon ab ob die
person beispielsweise schon polizeilich
in erscheinung getreten ist ob diese
person möglicherweise schon in
einschlägigen fällen mit gewalttaten
gegen frauen in der scheidung kid
witness die einen sexuell motivierten
hintergrund haben das ist etwas was die
ermittler und ermittlerin jetzt sehr
schnell prüfen müssen um nicht
tatsächlich dann noch menschliche
lebende opfer hier möglicherweise dann
bearbeiten zu müssen